they used a
childish cartoonish uh mechanism built
into the minds of many people to trigger
this i mean remember how anthony fauci
became anthony fauci to all of us in the
public who didn't know who he was
right
he was the guy who had his head in his
hands next to trump listening to
you know trump be unscientific at the
podium yeah that happens trump got some
stuff right and he got some stuff wrong
but the fact is anthony fauci was
visually in the minds of people the
mental alternative to trump which is why
he was imbued with uh
effectively a divine sense of truth
about him
which has well known it was also
as it turns out as you just said trump
got some stuff right and he got some
stuff wrong
as
kovit was emerging in that spring of
2020 and he was trump was being his
usual blustering
off the cuff
pain in the ass
bombast
it was really easy to think oh my god if
only we had someone who knew what they
were doing and and you could see
you could see some of the stuff that he
was just getting wrong and some of the
stuff's like no
could you not right and so to have
someone who appeared to have
you know the premature of science and of
history and of sobriety and of you know
just he was he was there on his own
recognizance and he knew what he was
doing to be to be to be in that sort of
face plant like oh i'm so dismayed to be
working for this man it felt like the
antidote and because it was easy for
many people to think
if not for trump we'd have this thing
kicked
we'd we'd
we'd know what to do and this would be
over already obviously it was going to
be fouchy was the answer right yeah and
that visual impression of the sober
scientific dweeby but highly competent
alternative to the bombast who reads
stuff on the internet and can't keep it
to himself right
that thing was architected and it you
know
just so happens that the sober
alternative happened to be a guy one of
a tiny number of people central to the
process of bypassing the gain of
function
research ban and offshoring the work to
the very lab that likely released this
thing right it it's almost beyond uh
it's so preposterous it's almost beyond
uh plausible no you would have taken a
few of those characteristics out of the
screenplay because it was going to be
too much it's too cartoonish
but i mean actually can we play the uh
the video of uh watch out you were
watching a video of anthony fauci um
earlier this week at the fred
hutchison cancer center in seattle um uh
speaking kind of off the cuff it's
interesting
it's called the fouchy effect which is
sort of like you know
as
trust me i'm i i don't get excited about
that
i mean it's nice but i mean
it's it's
i
people go to medical school
now people are interested in science not
because of me because people most people
don't know me who i am my friends know
me my wife knows me but people don't
know me it's what i symbolize and what i
symbolize
in a
in an era of
the normalization of untruths
and lies
and and all the things you're seeing
going on in society from
january 6th to everything else that goes
on
people the craving
for consistency for integrity for truth
and for people caring about people
anthony fauci
and i will not imitate him for uh
marital reasons for marital reasons
because i don't know if what he's got is
contagious but um
anyway he just would never be able to
look at you the same way what he
effectively says with uh
obvious uh glee glee delight pride all
of the you know i don't know how many
sins are involved but um i don't think
there's any gluttony
i'm sure there is um but uh
anyway trim
oh
the dude uh you know he's diminutive but
uh he cuts a fine figure but anyway
um
what does the man say he says that
apparently there's something dubbed the
fouchy effect so far as i can tell he
dubbed it the fountain effect but um
something called the fouchy effect in
which people are
they are applying to medical school um
because
his
scientific competent
blah blah blah modality has inspired
them to take up
um medicine
uh
by his model or something like this
which
because he says aye faushi symbolize
integrity and truth
not to me he doesn't well that's what
that is i just looked up the the little
little the little blurb that what what
actually does he say the fouchy effect
more and more people going to medical
school he claims
is because he symbolizes integrity and
truth especially and i think i'm
paraphrasing here in this era of
misinformation he invokes january 6th
yeah he invokes a range of things from
january 6 to
it's
whatever
yeah
my god it's been i mean really it's like
it's 52 seconds it's like 52 seconds and
he really crams a lot in there it's the
it's the equal of that one where he said
that he was science
yeah yeah and you know yeah it's so much
the man you know the wizard behind the
curtain but um anyway point being
this is the structure that decapitated
the thing that we the messy thing that
we used to have that figured out what
was true medically speaking and what
wasn't true and what to do about it um
they just supplanted the whole thing
yeah they got between your doctor and
your pharmacist something that is
unprecedented right and they just
started handing down these
these encyclicals that
changed the behavior of our entire
medical establishment and anyway i
wanted to point out a couple things
about this right so they're functioning
in a religious modality
they've i would argue tapped into
the religion-shaped whole issue that is
especially open for those people who are
secular
right which is going to be a higher
number of people on the left which is
part of why this is going to be more
effective high number of people highly
represented in science
but in any case
this is part and parcel of a radical
shift a radical revolution that is
taking over the entirety of the west
right what they've done
is they have begun to hand down by fiat
a description of
the truth right remember when they tried
to tell us
that the virus couldn't possibly have
emerged from the laboratory in wuhan
that was just a simple matter of well
here's the truth and we're handing it
down well there's i mean they're still
doing that i mean there's a recent
christian anderson paper that we
referenced a week or two ago yeah
they're still there they're they're on
that they're also sorry i know you're on
a roll here but um the cdc guideline the
new cdc guidelines also
kind of obscured the fact that now
yeah natural immunity is is real and
it's just as good as vaccine induced
immunity it may last longer right so
what hello again what did you say
because weren't we fighting over this
that you know there we were scientists
were being scoffed at for claiming that
natural immunity could possibly be a
real thing that having had covert you
might actually have immunity and
therefore not have to
submit to the you know also formulated
in the lab version of the immunity right
that came
via syringe and in fact you have
the oracle from on high handing down
uh
factual claims like natural immunity is
uh does in no way obviate the need for
uh
vaccination you have it participating
with
uh social media labeling
things that are true
as false you have the
the
department of homeland security
declaring
three kinds of falseness terrorism one
of which literally involves truth
which is inconvenient for government and
causes distrust of it right the whole
thing is about look here are the beliefs
you will now subscribe to their
relationship to reality is not the point
and anybody who feels an obligation to
reality is about to out themselves
because they're going to be forced to
mouth certain truths that are simply
false right the labels are going to be
reversed right this is all a matter of a
cult inflicting its new belief system
all of a sudden and it is going after
truth that is to say there is no major
journalistic establishment that is
independent
of this
the university system itself is mouthing
the shibboleths right history is being
rewritten by the same oracle-based
mechanism
right the the 1619 project etc we are
simply taking a version of history that
serves an ideology and we are imposing
it over actual history
we have the guilt and innocence of
people being a matter of uh encyclical
as well right so the raid on mar-a-lago
is supposedly justified by the fact that
this is the most law-breaking president
in history that's why we get to go after
people the way you know developing
countries used to you know political
factions used to go after each other
really what's he been convicted of right
the the so uh and even just the goodness
and badness of people right and this is
this is another place where the rubber
meets the road
human beings
because we have been forged by lineage
against lineage competition we are wired
for that just the same way we are wired
for religion we are wired to want to
know who's on the team and who isn't on
the team this is something that the west
did the best job yet of getting past and
is now being uninvented we have returned
to a place where we're supposed to
figure out oh who are the good people
and who are the people who are my enemy
right we are not supposed to say we are
all americans for example right and we
are united by that even over if we
differ over policy and what the wise
direction to go would be we are
americans first right no no the question
is who's good and who's bad right and
you know yeah sometimes that's the
question of you know who's jewish in
this case it could be a question of
who's vaccinated right but the point is
these things are all being handed down
by the same mechanism which is being
imposed over the superior mechanism that
the west yes it never completed the
project but the west innovated and
developed in which we had another method
for figuring this stuff out like
falsification
right like um you know
collaborating on a project even if we
disagree over the particulars right so
we are being returned to a previous
world without the benefit of the
narrative structure or ideology having
passed through the test of time and at
least being
valid in some sense right it's valid in
no sense it is in fact in direct
conflict with reality in a way that
causes people who follow it to do
very rapid self-harm right so this is um
i think this is becoming really clear
and if you are shocked by the attack on
salman rushdie you should be equally
shocked that a different flavor of the
same is taking over western civilization
and replacing all of the mechanisms that
have stood the test of time the only
alternative we have to that team-based
modality that is being replaced by
something in which
some oracle is going to decide
what you need to do what you need to
think who you need to attack and the
fact is there's just there's no future
in this
there is no future
we cannot play those games with the kind
of weaponry at our disposal we cannot
play those games with the number of
people on the planet we cannot play
those games with the amount of
industrial power at our disposal this is
just a fatal proposal
[Music]